on the second day after the Iowa caucus
the latest results showed that Pete
booter judge and Bernie Sanders are in a
very tight race with 71 percent of the
precincts reporting Budda judge seems to
be on track to win the state with nearly
27 percent of the state's delegates but
Sanders is ahead in the popular vote
let's head over to the decision desk
where tony is with CBS News elections
and surveys director that's Anthony
savant oh hey Gail thanks yes seems to
be on track is the key thing these
numbers are fascinating so let's dig
into them a little bit this is a map of
Iowa we've got the delegate count up
there Pete Buddha judge is leading in
the delegate count how did he have a
path to victory well Victor a possible
victory we've got the three quarters in
we finally got the data but when this
came in one of the things we saw Tony
was that Pete Buddha judge was doing
well and we lit those counties up in
blue all across I'll show you the
eastern part of the state up here in the
northeastern part where you were last
week and then across all the way through
the central part of the state as well
but you also want to point out that
Bernie Sanders does well around the
college towns he does well around Des
Moines
oh it just made the move mat move but
what we did here is we saw that we saw
around Iowa City all of that adds up to
that'll pop popular victory for Sanders
at this point 70 percent in now he's
claiming victory on what he's calling
the first count and the second count and
he's got more votes overall where was he
able to rack them up and how well let me
show you if you zoom in on here I'm
gonna switch this over to that pop watch
News member look at that Sanders goes up
and the reason for that Tony is that in
those college towns in those cities he
had high turnout there's not as many
delegates there so he doesn't go up on
the delegate count but he's gonna say
that he got more people to turn out for
him and that's a victory claim Budaj
edge is the youngest candidate in the
race would be the youngest president of
all time but how did he do
demographically with voters well let me
show you something from the entrance
poll this is when we talk to people who
work on their way into the caucasus
right to things that stuck out to me one
is the late deciders who broke towards
Pete Buddha just made up their mind in
the last couple of days that's what the
way they went and I'll show you this
Tony these young people okay that that
that is part of Sanders core base he
gets 48% of those folks under 30
you watch New Hampshire going forward
that's a group that's gonna stick with
him so they say in the polling really
interesting before we let you go we've
got to talk about Joe Biden Joe Biden
getting only 3% of the vote there among
people under the age of 30 but let's go
back to the big map I'm gonna go back to
the map and I'm gonna show you this Joe
Biden's big pitch to voters is he knows
how to win he's the one who can beat
President Trump but he's looking like
he's gonna be in fourth year in Iowa the
place to watch right here along this
line is that 15.4%
the dent the Democrats have a threshold
a cutoff you got to get over 15% to get
delegates so he's right on that line
we'll see if he makes it but certainly
not where he expected to be no not the
showing he was hoping for an team as we
toss back to you we remind you 30% of
the vote has yet to be kind of coat so
this could change but it appears that
people who the judge yesterday aren't on
our air when he said he felt victorious
he was on to something all right Tony
thanks